Aham mawero homi, abhya bhaja homi, Anigo homi, sukhya tanang pariharami, Dukham ujjami, yathalada sampatito, Mavikacchami.
Amakam chatupachaya dayaka,
Awera hontu, abhya bhaja hontu, Aniga hontu, sukhya tanang parihalantu, Dukhamu chantu, yathalada sampadzito, Mawika chantu.
A-ma-ka-ma-ta-pi-tu A-cha-ri-a-ny-a-ti-mi-ta-sa-mu-ha A-ve-ra-hon-tu A-pya-pa-ja-hon-tu A-ni-ga-hon-tu Su-ki-a-ta-na-ng-pa-ri-ha-lan-tu Du-ka-mu-chan-tu Ya-ta-la-da-sam-pa-ti-to
MAUI GACCHANTU HIMASMINGVI HARE SABBE BIKKU SABBA BIKKUNI SABBE ACCHARYA SABBE YOGINO AWERA HONTU ABHYABHAJA HONTU ANIGA HONTU SUKHYATANAM PARIHARANTU
Dukhamu chantu, yathalada sampatito, mawega chantu.
Imas mingame, janapade, yoropaya, lukas ming, save janata.
Awera hontu, abhya bhaja hontu.
Ani gahontu sukhiyatanam pariharantu Dukhamu chantu yatala dasampatito Mawe gachantu Puratimaya disaya pacimaya disaya Uttaraya disaya dakhinaya disaya
PURATIMAYANU DISAYA PACIMAYANU DISAYA UTTARAYANU DISAYA DAKINAYANU DISAYA HETIMAYA DISAYA UPARIMAYA DISAYA
Sabhe sata, sabhe pana, sabhe bhuta, sabhe bhukala, sabhe atavavahariya pana.
Sabha itiyo, sabhe purisa, sabhe ariya, sabhe anariya.
Sabe Deva, Sabe Manusa, Sabe Vinipatiha, Avera Hontu, Abhya Bhaja Hontu, Aniga Hontu, Sukhiya Tanang Parihalantu, Dukhamu Chantu, Yathalada Sampatito, Mawega Chantu.
Kamasaka.